Привет! Мы подошли к финалу модуля. Весь модуль мы разбирали инструменты, техники, модели,
промптинг, джейсон, создание стилей, мудбордов, апскейл, видео, ноды и так далее. Курсовая работа — всё это,
как ни странно, собирает в одну единую работу. Это не учебный проект ради галочки, тут ты делаешь
уже визуал под свой сквозной продукт, тот самый, с которым шёл в первом и втором модулях. Задача у
нас достаточно простая по формулировке и ёмкая по содержанию — закрыть визуальные потребности
своего продукта. Не одна красивая картинка, а набор, который держится в едином стилевом языке и
реально пригоден в продукте. Сначала карта, по которой делается любой артефакт. Это сводные
pipeline-модули и каждый его шаг ты уже проходил. Шаг первый — это задача. Что именно нужно? Иллюстрация,
обложка, баннер, продуктовый шот — в зависимости от того, с каким продуктом ты работаешь. Второй — это
выбор модели. Не по названию, а по тем четырём критериям, что мы держим в голове. Второй — это выбор модели.
Если мы говорим об изображениях, то что нам нужно: креативность, либо точность. Возможно,
сначала креативность, потом доработка с помощью более точных моделей и так далее. Это мы всё уже
смотрели. Если это видео, то нужно определить, по какому мы двигаемся сценарию. Либо полностью
покадрово всё видео планируем, либо запускаем один раз генерацию. Но также собираем промпты,
собираем стилистику, оформляем это всё желательно в JSON, но можно и без этого, если ты справишься.
Генерируем это всё, собираем воедино, апскейлим и на выходе получаем пайплайн, который будет
воспроизводиться, в котором можно продолжать дальше генерировать сколько угодно подобного контента.
Именно сам блок сборки уже на твоё усмотрение. Ноды — это очень объёмная
тема. Сам блок сборки по твоему усмотрению. Ты можешь делать на нодах, можешь делать самостоятельно в
разных инструментах, в крии и так далее. Главное — выстроить прозрачный пайплайн. Я допускаю,
что на ноды может просто не хватить времени, потому что тема очень объёмная. Если бы каждый
отдельный нод мы рассматривали, применяли где-то и так далее, на это ушёл бы минимум целый
модуль, а то и больше. Да и в целом, при таком объёме информации ты вряд ли что-то запомнишь.
Поэтому это то место, где нужно самостоятельно посмотреть, что есть, поэкспериментировать,
посмотреть готовые примеры. И только тогда это будет откладываться в памяти. В предыдущем
уроке я показал всё самое основное, как это работает, где что брать, что точно тебе пригодится.
Дальше уже на своё усмотрение. Дальше. Какие у нас критерии, которые говорят о том,
что у нас к продакшену всё готово? Во-первых, это разрешение под задачу, то есть должны быть
изображения, исходники высокого качества. Я думаю, это и так понятно. Далее — это единый стиль,
мы уже знаем, как их собирать, мы знаем, как воспроизводить их с помощью JSON-промптов.
Также адаптация под все основные форматы — это 1:1, 16:9 и 9:16. Не обязательно вообще все твои
исходники через это прогонять, просто в твоём пайплайне должна быть выстроена прозрачная
система, в которой ты всё это можешь сделать. Ну и просто чистота. Если бы ты не был готов
это отдать в прод на реальном продукте, то и здесь это значит, что ещё результат сырой.
Не должно быть странных артефактов, шестируких людей, смазанного текста и так далее.
Что именно собирать зависит от твоего продукта. Разложу на три типа, тут можешь поискать свой.
Я здесь разложу на три основных типа, просто чтобы привести пример. Если продукт утилитарный,
там B2B-сервис или дашборд, то тебе нужны логотип, 3-4 иллюстрации пустых состояний и один
промо-баннер. Этого будет достаточно. Пустые состояния — это то, чего в таких продуктах
вечно не хватает и где визуал реально работает. Если это маркетплейс или e-ком, то карточка товара,
лайфстайл, кадр, обложки по категориям, продуктовый шот, сборка продукта в сцене.
Если это контент-продукт, то обложки, иллюстрации, продуктовые шоты под твой контент.
Минимум. Общий для всех — это единый стилевой язык плюс 5-7 готовых артефактов.
Не гони за количеством. Лучше немного, но согласованных артефактов с понятным прозрачным пайплайном,
чем огромное количество разных изображений, которые в дальнейшем ты воспроизвести не сможешь.
Опять же, отмечу еще раз, самое главное, чтобы у нас был визуал и был понятный пайплайн.
Ноды уже по желанию. Итак, сдача курсового проекта. И если ты все-таки собираешь на нодах,
это замечательно. Ты можешь просто прислать ссылку на свой проект, и я уже сам смогу все
посмотреть, разобрать. Ничего дополнительно сопутствующего мне прилагать не нужно. Если же ты
будешь отдельно генерировать в разных инструментах, пользоваться там md-файлами, расширять это все с агентом,
то мне нужно структурное описание того, где у тебя, что генерируется, в какой модели,
почему это работает так, почему ты выбирал это. В целом, если ты будешь делать это вместе со своей
средой, там же генерировать промпты и так далее, то она для тебя и в фиг джеме отрисует всю карту
вот этих решений, с которой будет уже удобнее работать. Ну и там же в фигме ты можешь прикрепить уже
реальные артефакты, показать какой у тебя получился визуал. В такой форме сдавать сложнее,
поэтому лучше все-таки в нодах разобраться, как это все собрать. На этом всем, удачи с
выполнением курсового проекта и увидимся в следующем модуле.